to this day I've never been more mobbed
in my life which is kind of interesting
so I spoke at this event as the resident
brick and mortar expert and all these
people came up to me and they're like
what can I buy from you what courses do
you have and I was like I'm a gym owner
like I was like I just showed you what I
did finally one guy handed me his credit
card and said charge me for $5,000 and
tell me what I get later it was really
weird and I had a hundred business cards
in my pocket from that one talk so I got
home and of course like as any good
salesman I like put everything into my
Excel sheet of all the names and all the
numbers and I hit up every single person
I called the guy up and gave me the
credit card I was like do you really
want me to run this cuz like I don't
have anything he's like yeah run it I
was like all right so I ran it for
$5,000 and immediately he was like all
right what do I get I was like uh it
just so happened he had a gym that
needed to open I was like great I'll
just launch your gym for you I'll fly
out I'll sit at your front desk and I'll
just fill the gym up that was actually
how the first gym launch happened